[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend herr um es gleich zu sagen
ist ist weder uns noch anderen gelungen
klarheit zu schaffen in der wichtigen
frage gibt es genügend impfstoff um alle
ziele und wünsche zu erfüllen das ist
keine einfache sache es ist nämlich auch
eine frage der zeit
bundesregierung und kommission in
brüssel wollen offensichtlich so schnell
wie möglich so viel wie möglich
heranschaffen erstes quartal
2022 irgendwann ist nicht gut genug märz
wäre zu spät sagte lauterbach heute der
druck aufs gaspedal ist in dieser
schärfe neu es geht darum der
undurchsichtigen omikron variante die
chance auf ausbreitung zu versperren so
schnell wie möglich und da hilft es dass
impfmüdigkeit und skepsis offenbar
schwinden der ernst der lage wird
zunehmend erkannt und zwar von denen auf
die es wirklich ankommt die sogenannten
ganz normalen bürger die regierung muss
liefern die nachfrage ist jetzt da
andreas huppert berichtet
tapfer ist der sechsjährige jesko ohne
mit der wimper zu zucken erträgt er den
stich corona impfung die erste für ihn
lange haben sie in der familie
diskutiert sich schließlich für den
schritt entschieden
in anderen ländern sind kinder auch mehr
betroffen als es bis jetzt der fall war
und ich denke dass einfach dass das der
weg ist aus dieser pandemie rauszukommen
hamburg asklepios klinik nord hier haben
sie es heute nur auf die kleinen
abgesehen kinder im alter von fünf bis
elf jahren werden gefixt doch impfstoff
ist mangelware
das ist eine knappe zu verzeichnen aber
wir nehmen jetzt jeden im stoff der da
ist ich hoffe die produktion kann auch
dann hochgefahren werden das ist
eigentlich meine verantwortung
allerdings seine verantwortung so karl
lauterbach in seiner ersten
bundespressekonferenz gemeinsam mit dem
lka chef sollte es hauptsächlich ums
kinder impfen gehen doch irgendwie
geriet das zur nebensache denn im raum
steht deutschland hat zu wenig impfstoff
zu wenig für kinder zu wenig zum
boostern zu wenig für alle die den stoff
wollen
wir haben halt eine sehr offensive
booster impfung strategie zu unserem
also hauptwerkzeug gemacht und dafür
braucht man sehr viel impfstoff und
dafür braucht man den impfstoff schnell
und ließen eben stoff zu beschaffen
damit habe ich begonnen versucht uns
ausdrücklich keine kritiker mal und
vorgänger das sehen die parteifreunde
von vorgänger sparen aber mal ganz
anders sie weisen den vorwurf das
gesundheitsministerium habe eine bestell
optionen bei der eu verstreichen lassen
mit abscheu zurück karl lauterbach muss
selbst entscheiden wie er kommuniziert
am ende kann ich nur sagen jens spahn
hat sich sehr intensiv dafür eingesetzt
dass jetzt genug impfstoff zur verfügung
steht dass wir die booster impfung bis
ende des jahres mit über 30 millionen
schaffen können dafür ist genug
impfstoff da und für das erste quartal
ist er zuständig dafür muss er liefern
politischer streit hin oder her tatsache
ist es fehlt an impfstoff und das womit
omikron eine neue virusvariante im
anmarsch ist was aber jetzt schon klar
ist allein dadurch dass omikron so
extrem ansteckend ist dass sich
innerhalb eines zeitraums noch mehr
menschen infizieren können müssen wir
mit einer hohen zahl an schweren
verläufen rechnen deshalb hat lauterbach
bei bayer und tag reserviert und
nachgeordert 2,2 milliarden euro wird es
kosten neuer impfstoff gegen die neue
variante
es wird zum größten teil schon
angepasster impfstoff seien also
impfstoff der auf die omikron variante
schon angepasst ist ich hoffe dass wir
von diesen 80 millionen dosen noch einen
teil im ersten quartal bekommen hoffen
heißt nicht sicher wissen in hamburg
haben sie bis jahresende noch sechs
weitere kinder impft tage geplant mit
350 dosen biontech alle termine sind
jetzt schon vergeben ob auch genügend
impfstoff verfügbar ist das steht
allerdings auf einem anderen blatt
tino sorge der gesundheitspolitische
sprecher der unions fraktion wirft
lauterbach vor einen dramatischen
impfstoffmangel zu inszenieren damit er
als retter da stehen kann es gebe gar
keinen mangel sagt er nah sein möchte
mir fragt den später im journal update
wie er da so sicher sein kann der
bundestag hat heute nebenbei zeit um
einen fast historischen umbruch in der
gesäß geografie zu vollziehen es ist ja
nicht egal wer wo sitzt im parlament
traditionell gilt von der präsidentin
bank aus gesehen je weiter rechts desto
nationaler konservativer je weiter links
desto je nach weltanschauung
progressiver sozialer sozialistischer
diese aufteilung geht 200 jahre zurück
auf frankreichs nationalversammlung
damals nahm sich der natürlich
konservative adel das alte regime die
traditionellen ehrenplätze zur rechten
des präsidenten links ließen sie platz
für niedrige stände und linkes gesorgt
die begriffe links und rechts gelten
aber rund um die welt bis heute fast wie
das mehrheitsprinzip und heute hat die
neue ampel mehrheit die union aus der
mitte gedrückt thomas reichert und
christian kirsch über sitz und
weltordnung wenn es noch eines belegs
bedurft hätte dass es eigentlich nur die
afg neben der afg aushält dann lieferte
ihn an diesem nachmittag stefan brandner
mit geschimpfe in richtung fdp wie man
sie zumindest vom rednerpult selten hört
je näher die sich so an die macht
heranrückten desto blasierter wurde
diese machtversessene macht vergessene
grün-links devote posten grapscher
truppe von der fdp aggressiv wie hier
der damalige fdp fraktionschef roland
mit vielen versteckten fouls und
beschimpfungen das sei der
parlamentarische stil der hfg klagt die
fdp
nicht was sich hier abspielt und ich
möchte dass nur das was jeder weiß diese
despektierliche art hier in diesem hause
ist unerträglich
die bisherige sitzordnung im parlament
sieht sowas
links die linke daneben die spd dann die
grünen dann die union die fdp und
daneben seit 2000 sitzen die afd seit
2017 will die fdp weg von der afg in die
mitte und hat dafür in der ampel
koalition jetzt die mehrheit fdp grüne
und spd sitze nun beisammen die union
gold sie möchten uns von unseren plätzen
an den rand des plenums drücken sie
möchten einen monolithischen block in
der mitte statuieren sie möchten für die
mehrheit die zentralen plätze hier im
plenum haben und es ist nicht in ordnung
es geht dabei um inhaltliches wer wo
sitzt bedeutet auch wer wo steht und es
geht um mehrheit und macht im plenum die
union hat in der vergangenheit andere
oft eben diese macht spüren lassen hat
in hessen und bayern umgekehrt die fdp
zum platztausch gezwungen da sind sie
doch nicht von arroganz der macht
wenn sie dazu
nur bayern machen liebe kollegen von
regierung und ihren lassen wir uns da
nichts zu arroganz der macht erzählt
wahrlich nicht auch die linke hat wenig
mitgefühl mit der union und ihrem platz
wechsel in die opposition
ich finde das schon relativ viel mehr
und wird das würde ja mal sagen wie sie
und ihre fraktion 30 jahren mit meiner
partei damals der pds und dann der
linksfraktion umgegangen sind und sich
jetzt hier hinstellen weil es jetzt
ihnen einmal hier an den kragen geht
diese weinerlichkeit das ist wirklich
vertrauen zu sehen einmal sagt es allen
kursen zu besonders leicht mit den
stimmen der ampel und der linken
beschließt das parlament die neue
sitzordnung zeichen auch der neuen
hackordnung
bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat diese
zentrale debatte nicht mitbekommen er
ist heute zum ersten mal als
regierungschef eingebunden in einen
gipfel der europäischen union und nicht
irgendeinen das thema heute abend könnte
nicht ernster sein es geht um den
frieden im osten europas und zwar sehr
bald es geht darum einen krieg um die
oder in der ukraine zu verhindern der
vielleicht schon im januar droht die
truppen die es dafür bräuchte hat putin
nach erkenntnissen der nato längst in
stellung gebracht das geschehen gönnt
dem neuen kanzler keine schonzeit
florian neumann berichtet so schweigsam
der neue aus deutschland die minuten vor
beginn des gipfels verbringt so wenig
berät ist er zuvor auch vor den kameras
wie europa auf einen russischen angriff
auf die ukraine reagieren würde ist die
frage der antwort fällt auf worüber olaf
scholz nicht redet sanktionen ich glaube
wichtig ist dass wir uns immer dazu
bekennen dass es sichere grenzen gibt
dass sie unverletzt bleiben und dass wir
das alle gemeinsam festlegen nicht jeder
hält sich so zurück je näher das eigene
land an russland desto höher die
erwartungen so fordern die baltischen
regierungen schon jetzt eine drastische
antwort auf russische truppen aufmärsche
denken etwa an die russische gaspipeline
nord stream 2 die zwar fertig gebaut
aber noch nicht in betrieb ist wir
werden dieses thema aufbringen denn das
ist eines der instrumente das in der
beziehung zu russland sehr stark wirken
könnten sich eine mehrheit der
regierungschefinnen und chefs aber will
mögliche sanktionen nicht öffentlich
machen drum russland die eigenen trümpfe
nicht zu verraten zur selben zeit besuch
des ukrainischen staatschefs bei der
nato und deren generalsekretär verrät
etwas anderes wie wenig die drohungen
des westens bisher bewirkt haben sie
sehen keine anzeichen dass der russische
truppen aufgestockt oder sich
verlangsamt im gegenteil er geht weiter
jede militärische gewalt durch russland
werde massive konsequenzen haben auf
diese beinahe standard warnung können
sie sich heute beim eu-gipfel einigen
standardmäßig ohne zu sagen welche
christiansen ist unser mann in moskau
christian wird dort überhaupt
wahrgenommen was europa da berät und
beschließt
ja das wird mit so einer ich würde sagen
gewissen schadenfreude wahrgenommen bis
zum abend gab es ist noch keine großen
öffentlichen äußerungen oder kommentare
zu dem gipfel es gab diverse berichte in
staatlichen medien und da ist man sich
doch einig dass sich europa mal wieder
nicht einig ist dieses bild zeichnet man
hier ja immer wieder gerne das erkennen
wir auch in anderen fällen der ständige
vertreter in brüssel russlands der hat
noch aus russischer sicht wohlwollend
kommentiert das ist ja auch keine
beschränkungen keine beschlüsse gegen
nord stream 2 gab gegen dieses prestige
projekt also die lesart ist hier so ein
bisschen manchmal wird viel geredet in
europa und zum schluss dann nichts
beschlossen und was die normalen
russinnen und russen also die menschen
die auf der straße sind was die über
diesen konflikt denken da ist mein
eindruck dass das eigentlich keine große
rolle spielen und dass die meisten hier
eigentlich nicht glauben dass es bald zu
einem krieg kommen könnte und ist es ja
leider eindeutig dass russland im
grenzgebiet zur ukraine truppen
zusammengezogen hat die ausreichen
würden für einen massiven eingriff
welchen zweck könnte das haben ohne das
ist ein krieg wird
wladimir putin das hat er auch immer
wieder betont und wiederholt will vor
allem sicherheitsgarantien haben dass
sich die nato nicht richtung osten
erweitert und ich glaube er will der
präsident sein der das in irgendeiner
form manifestiert und wenn er dann im
gespräche geht mit europa oder auch mit
den usa es gab er kürzlich ein video
gipfel mit joe biden und es gibt
möglicherweise bald noch ein gespräch
mit joe biden da geht man mit einem ganz
anderen rückenwind und so ein gespräch
und auch aus einer position der stärke
das ist glaube ich hier das kalkül man
kann sogar aus dieser position der
gespräche in gewisser weise auch
erzwingen und ein weiterer nebeneffekt
dürfte natürlich auch sein dass man auch
europa uneins zeigen kann dass nicht
klar ist wer in europa die führungsrolle
hat dass sich europa anti russisch zeigt
und das ist dann eher eine botschaft die
dann wiederum hier nach innen gerichtet
ist das die erklärung wäre wäre
sozusagen bestmögliche fall dankeschön
christian lammers kam und plötzlich
wirken meldungen rund ums pandemie
geschehen ein bisschen kleiner in
niedersachsen ist die 2g regel für den
einzelhandel außer kraft gesetzt das
oberverwaltungsgericht in lüneburg
urteilte zweig schränke die grundrechte
ungeimpfter kunden und von ladeninhabern
ein und sei zum infektionsschutz nicht
notwendig auch in anderen bundesländern
haben einzelhändler gegen die 2g regel
geklagt die bundesweite inzidenz sinkt
weiter auf aktuell 3 140,1 das rk ii
meldete 56
1677 neuinfektionen innerhalb eines
tages 13
1934 weniger als vor einer woche
anhaltend hoch die zahl der todesfälle
522 kamen dazu
bundesfinanzminister lindner hat den
geplanten nachtragshaushalt mit
umschichtungen von milliardenkrediten im
bundestag gegen massive kritik
verteidigt
folgeschäden der pandemie müssten
abgefedert durch die krise
vernachlässigte investitionen dringend
nachgeholt werden dagegen hält die
opposition die umschichtung für
verfassungswidrig corona kredite in
klimaschutz und digitalisierung zu
investieren höhle die schuldenbremse aus
die bundesanwaltschaft hat knapp zwei
jahre nach dem rassistischen anschlag
von hanau das ermittlungsverfahren gegen
unbekannt eingestellt es gebe keine
anhaltspunkte dass der attentäter
unterstütze oder mitwisser gehabt habe
auch bestünde kein verdacht gegen den
vater der 43 jährige deutsche hatte im
februar vergangenen jahres aus
rassistischen motiven neun menschen mit
migrationshintergrund erschossen und
zahlreiche weitere zum teil schwer
verletzt anschließend tötete er in
seinem elternhaus seine mutter und sich
selbst
vor knapp zwei jahren ebenfalls kam es
im nordhessischen volkmarsen zu einer
auto attacke auf den rosenmontagszug
heute hat das landgericht kassel den
fahrer wegen 89 fachen mordversuchs zu
einer lebenslangen haftstrafe verurteilt
zudem stellten die richter die besondere
schwere der schuld des heute 31 jährigen
fest nach ihrer überzeugung vor der
angeklagte am 24 februar 2020
vorsätzlich in den karnevalsumzug er
verletzte dabei 89 menschen darunter
viele kinder
das motiv bleibt unklar auch heute
schwieg der mann zu den vorwürfen
keine frau der präsident von human
rights watch der großen weltweit
operierenden menschenrechtsorganisation
hat einmal festgestellt dass die derzeit
gefährlichste arbeit die von aktivisten
für die umwelt sei die seien
typischerweise dort unterwegs wo mafiöse
strukturen sich naturschätze unter den
nagel reißen und dafür sorgen dass
behörden und justiz von korruption
durchsetzt sind dort gibt es keinen
schutz das gilt dann auch für
journalistinnen und journalisten die
solchen organisationen auf der spur sind
porto ohne grenzen stellt im
jahresbericht
2021 heute fest dass die verfolgung von
journalisten durch autoritäre staaten
und kriminelle um 20 prozent zugenommen
hat auf ein allzeithoch barbara völkel
berichtet eine auch da ungewöhnliche
geschichte aus europa aus den
rumänischen karpaten
rumänien westkap arten europas letzte
urwälder
der wald ist der gefährlichste ort für
einen journalisten
ich wurde bedroht ich wurde geschlagen
ich wurde angegriffen weil wir das wahre
gesicht der holzmafia zeigen
allein im swat tal verschwanden durch
illegale abholzung laut rumänischem
umweltministerium fast 40.000 kubikmeter
holz wert und zwei millionen euro
die methoden der holzmafia kennen sie
ganz genau rumänische journalisten wie
alex media- und tiberius shooter
dieses video dokumentiert wie gefährlich
recherchen über die holzmafia sein
können ein geschäftsmann bremst alex
media mit absicht aus warum wirst du vor
mein auto gefahren hier ist eine
öffentliche straße
aber warum films du hier mein holz wir
sind hier auf einer öffentlichen straße
ich bin journalist und dafür filmen
verschwinde weltweit leben journalistin
journalisten immer dann gefährlich wenn
sie über umweltverbrechen berichten also
dann wenn politik und unternehmen
gemeinsame sache machen gegen die umwelt
noch nie waren so viele journalisten
journalisten weltweit hinter gefängnis
gittern wie in diesem jahr weltweit
488 inhaftierte journalisten ein anstieg
von 20 prozent gegenüber dem vorjahr
auch in osteuropa
mit hilfe einer 24 stunden
videoüberwachung und einer speziellen
website überprüft tiberius shooter die
kennzeichen der lastwagen ob eine
genehmigung zum holztransport vorliegt
doch bei tausenden von lkw ist das nicht
der fall er meldete dass der polizei
die reaktion der polizei war darauf sehr
drastisch ich wurde noch nie so schlecht
behandelt auch förster haben nicht
deshalb geschlagen die probleme kommen
von den behörden von der polizei wurde
ich sogar angezeigt wegen belästigung
musste noch eine geldstrafe bei der
polizei bezahlen
[Musik]
und tobago shooter kassiert prügel von
der holzmafia
los zieh dich aus zügig aus was suchst
du hier jährlich zum teufel es ist nicht
in ordnung was ihr hier mit mir machen
die bergische tag kommt mit dem leben
davon
beobachten recherchieren berichten
mutige journalisten schaffen
öffentlichkeit alex media- und tiberius
shooter werden nicht aufgeben denn auf
dem spiel stehen die letzten urwälder
europas
vor zwei jahren war das corona virus so
ziemlich das letzte was das
weltfinanzsystem brauchen konnte nach
den großen krisen rauchten ja die
bazooka sste finanzminister noch leer
geschossen die hatten die märkte mit
geld geflutet
whatever it takes als gäbe es kein
morgen
aber morgen kam und das virus und es
fangen die wirtschaft in die knie und
wieder wurden schleusen geöffnet
irgendwann musst du dir dieses ganzes
geld diese gewaltigen schulden entwertet
werden das war die alte regel
offensichtlich gilt sie noch geld
schwimmen führen offenbar auch im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert zu
inflation mittlerweile steigen die
preise bei null zins der banken das
heißt sparguthaben schmelzen weg
zentralbanken in usa großbritannien
steuern jetzt dagegen drucken weniger
geld drehen zinsen nach oben
und die europäische zentralbank tut das
nicht das ist ein umstrittener kurs
berichtet stefan schlosser
autofahrer merken es an der tankstelle
auch beim einkaufen rind das geld
schneller durch die finger die inflation
ist längst im portemonnaie der
verbraucher angekommen 5,2 prozent im
november so hoch wie seit fast 30 jahren
nicht der druck auf die ezb ist in den
vergangenen monaten deutlich gestiegen
doch die währungshüter bleiben bei ihrer
einschätzung die inflationsraten würden
wieder sinken wenn auch nicht ganz so
stark wie vor kurzem noch angenommen
im laufe des jahres 2022 erwarten wir
eine stabilisierung der energiepreise
eine normalisierung des
verbraucherverhaltens und ein abklingen
des preisdrucks aufgrund globaler
lieferengpässe
das gigantische corona hilfsprogramm mit
einem volumen von
1,85 billionen euro will die ezb im märz
war auslaufen lassen doch das heißt
nicht dass künftig weniger geld im
umlauf ist oder nicht jederzeit
nachgelegt werden könnte einerseits wird
das notfall ankaufprogramm
zurückgefahren andererseits hat man sie
hintertüren offen gelassen das standard
ankaufprogramm wurde sogar aufgestockt
die rückführung des ankaufs von
staatsanleihen ist damit zögerlich und
von daher kennen wir eigentlich davon
ausgehen dass die geldpolitik der ezb
weiter in denen er expansiv sein wird
und damit ganz anders als die anderer
notenbanken die amerikanische fed hat
gestern vorgelegt und eine zinswende
angekündigt die bank of england setzt er
heute noch einen drauf und erhöhte den
leitzins schon jetzt als erster der
großen notenbanken für die ezb soll es
zwar eigentlich nur um preisstabilität
gehen doch ihre maßnahmen sprechen für
viele eine andere sprache
es ist ganz klar die ezb will mit ihrer
politik auch hoch verschuldete staaten
stützen sie will sogar künftig bei dem
bei auslaufenden staatsanleihen
verstärkt die griechische anleihen
kaufen in diesem punkt machte ezb
fiskalpolitik keine geldpolitik und das
sollte sie nicht eine zentralbank kann
es eben nicht 19 mitgliedern des
euroraums gleichermaßen recht machen
irgendwer zahlt immer auch im nächsten
jahr wird kein jahr für zins pfarrerin
und spritsparer sein denn gerade
inflation ist sind sparend geplante
vermögensvernichtung und leider muss man
sagen die inflation wird die preise hoch
halten das heißt die verbraucher müssten
noch mehr in die tasche greifen um die
güter des alltäglichen lebens bezahlen
zu können denn billiger wird es ja nicht
die preise steigen nur etwas langsamer
wenn denn die ezb mit ihrer einschätzung
recht behält
und genau darüber wird an der
frankfurter börse diskutiert das
festhalten an der nullzinspolitik auch
heftig kritisiert so mal zum beispiel
sparkassenpräsident schläfer ist die
inflation sei mit macht zurück gekehrt
sina mainitz da haben deutsche
verbraucher in der eurozone ja besondere
probleme ja so ist es denn sie bekommen
immer weniger für ihr geld bisher blick
die ezb zwar auf die steigende inflation
ihre mittel dagegen reichen aber eben
nicht aus um sie einzudämmen die
notenbanken in den usa oder in
großbritannien haben ja bereits reagiert
und die leitzinsen erhöht oder ist
zumindest angekündigt mit einer
inflation von zuletzt knapp 7 prozent
stand die us notenbank fed aber auch
unter deutlich höherem zugzwang als die
europäische zentralbank und man muss
bedenken dass die fed eben nicht den
ganzen währungsraum im blick haben muss
anders als die notenbank der gesamten
eurozone er und einen ausstieg aus der
nullzinspolitik hätte ja auch massive
folgen für die hoch verschuldeten
euro-länder die eurozone ist eben eine
währungsunion und die europäische
zentralbank stellt die stabilität dieser
gemeinschaft über die interessen
einzelner länder sie macht sozusagen
politik für das schwächste glied zwar
profitierte deutschland von höheren
zinsen in südeuropäischen ländern
hingegen würde der schuldenberg wachsen
und am ende dass die eurozone noch viel
mehr geld kosten
hinzu kommt dass die ezb künftig einiges
finanzieren muss den klimaschutz die
digitalisierung oder die infrastruktur
in der eurozone da kommen niedrige
zinsen dann eben gerade recht in
deutschland bleibt das sparbuch
weiterhin weniger attraktiv als die
anlage am aktienmarkt der dax hat heute
ein prozent hinzugewonnen
vielen dank sie nach frankfurt beim
flugzeugbauer airbus ist eine ära zu
ende gegangen der letzte großraumflieger
a380 wurde ausgeliefert nur 16 jahre
nach dem erstflug die arabische airline
emirates erhielt die letzte bestellte
maschine wegen der pandemie ohne gäste
damit endet das prestige objekt mit dem
möglichst viele passagiere mit möglichst
wenigen flugzeugen transportiert werden
sollten gefragt sind heute kleinere
preisgünstigere maschinen mit geringeren
treibstoffverbrauch anmeldung vom sport
snowboarder stefan baumeister hat dem
deutschen team im olympia-winter den
ersten weltcup sieg der saison beschert
im italienischen carezza setzte sich der
28-jährige aus oberbayern im
parallel-riesenslalom gegen weltmeister
dimitri lockt ihn oft durch der russisch
nicht wegen eines fahrfehlers aus
baumeister führt die disziplin wertung
nun an
[Musik]
paris ganz frankreich ehrt den
deutsch-französischen
jahrhundertkünstler an seinem kiefer mit
einer ausstellung im grand palais
sie ist groß wie kiefers werk groß ist
großartige kunst über große schwere
themen zu verstehen nur vor dem
hintergrund der gewaltigen europäischen
deutschen französischen geschichte sie
lässt kiefer nicht los so wie kiefer
seine betrachter nicht loslässt christel
haas unsere korrespondentin in paris
besuchte da eine ausstellung die von
anfang an ein ereignis ist
verszeilen mit kreide auf die gemälde
geschrieben daneben ein bunker und auf
allen eine widmung für porzellan er ist
anselm kiefers persönlicher held dieser
dichter der seine erinnerungen an den
holocaust mit poesie verarbeitete die
bilder überdimensional wie tafeln stehen
sie im spärlich beleuchteten raum und
dann habe ich gedacht ich kann da auf
diese schiefertafel die der oper
entstanden ist der himmel ist er mich
wie eine schiefertafel hier kann ich ein
gedicht schreiben ich wollte vor allen
dingen auch dass der elan hier
zuerst wahrgenommen wird und nicht nicht
er denn nicht der maler es sind dunkle
werke die doch leuchten sie erzählen von
unheil krieg verfolgung tod immer
plastisch mit stroh stoff steinen der
nationalsozialismus das nicht vergessen
sind die immerwährenden themen von
anselm kiefer auch deshalb ist diese
ausstellung eine mahnung an europa
wir müssen aufpassen
weil was hinter uns lichtaugen sichtlich
hinter uns licht
kann wie das sofort da sein
gemeinsamkeit statt konfrontation lernen
aus der deutschen geschichte wie kommt
das bei den franzosen an
es passt ich die ausstellung ist sehr
sehr intensiv die großen werke der ort
der wirklich magisch ist und er alles
besonders gut zur geltung bringt es hat
mich extrem berührt
werke eines künstlers der in frankreich
lebt und deutscher ist das zeigt wie
stark die bindung zwischen beiden
ländern ist
ich habe mir ein buch das sich das
gekauft es wäre noch bewegender gewesen
wenn es eine übersetzung zu den texten
auf den gemälden gegeben hätte
die ausstellung gibt auch einblicke in
kiefers atelier ein sammelsurium von
scherben bis hin zu asche
die gemälde stehen auf rollen als würden
sie ihren standort immer wieder
verändern alles ist im fluss auch das
künstlerische schaffen von anselm kiefer
selbst
[Musik]
ich bin als ich grundsätzlich
verzweifelt weil ich nicht das hauptwerk
schafft meine bilder sind immer im
werden diese werden immer umgearbeitet
ich bin aber ansonsten ein lustiger
mensch was für ein künstler
diese ausstellung jedenfalls hinterlässt
eine dauerhafte wirkung
und müssen ein weiterer grund nach paris
zu reisen man muss ich ein bisschen
beeilen bis zum 11 januar die runde bei
maybrit illner mit friedrich merz lars
craemer daniel cohn bendit und bettina
schausten macht weiter wo wir begonnen
haben die neuen wirren um pandemie
impfung und impfstoff und um 0.30 meldet
sich nah sein möchte mir mit unserem
heute-journal update bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend das hoch zafira bringt uns
eine sehr ruhige wetterlage sonnenschein
gibt es da nur wenig allerdings auch
keine große kälte die verbirgt sich hier
nördlich von dem tief matteo in russland
es wird sich allerdings an dieser
wetterlage etwas ändern denn dieses hoch
über west- und mitteleuropa wird bis
anfang kommender woche weiter in
richtung norden ziehen und damit ist der
weg frei für die größere kälte aus osten
und das könnte bedeuten dass es anfang
nächster woche zumindest mal im osten
deutschlands mal wieder etwas schnee
gibt sie sehen allerdings auch über dem
atlantik ein neues tief und wie schnell
das herankommt und milde luft mitbringt
ist noch völlig unklar klar dagegen dass
es in dieser nacht meist bedeckt bleibt
hin und wieder bildet sich nebel das
kann auch ein bisschen nieselregen geben
im nordosten es ist zum teil klar die
temperaturen sinken meist auf 7 bis 2
grad kälter wird es über schnee an den
alpen auch im schwarzwald auf der
schwäbischen alb mit null bis minus 5
grad und genau am alpenrand bleibt es
morgen auch am kühlsten mit 3 grad sonst
ist es für mitte dezember recht mild bei
4 bis 10 grad ähnliche heute ist es auch
morgen eher trüb bei uns und es gibt nur
zwei regionen wo sich auch mal die sonne
zeigen kann zum einen hier im nordosten
zwischen berlin brandenburg und der
ostseeküste und westlich des rheins und
zwischen dem oberrhein und dem allgäu in
den nächsten tagen wird es von tag zu
tag zwar kälter aber wir sehen doch mehr
und mehr die sonne schön ab